the Department of Homeland Security is
pressing Congress for more powers to
stop malicious drones that could
threaten the United States intelligence
officials are increasingly concerned
about the use of drones by terrorists
and drug cartels only on CBS this
morning Jeff Pegues got a rare access to
some drones in action at a Customs and
Border Protection facility in Tucson
Arizona this is one of the drones that
CBP uses to fly along the us-mexico
border and when they put this up in the
sky they're using it to look for people
who are attempting to cross the border
illegally but they're also looking for
drones used by drug cartels to surveil
law enforcement but according to US
officials there's another looming threat
out there and that's the threat of
terrorist organizations potentially
using drones to target the u.s. high on
a hill overlooking the vast us-mexico
border a team of Customs and Border
Patrol agents is putting together a
high-tech drone designed to scan the
terrain it's looking for illegal
activity and now law enforcement is
concerned bad actors will use their own
drones to target the u.s. look around
out here the us-mexico border is wide
open for the use of drones some
maliciously and that's what US officials
are really concerned about that a
terrorist organization could take
advantage of that we walked part of the
border with DHS's top intelligence
official David Lowery and Customs and
Border Patrol chief Rodolfo Carrick you
want to move people narcotics
god forbid weapons of mass destruction
or anything else over the border you
have a surveillance location the Camino
automated with drones at a very
inexpensive cost by organizations
outside of the United States what was
impossible for terrorist organizations
is now possible perfected drone used to
drop precision bombs on their enemies
and in Venezuela this summer as
President Nicolas Maduro gave a speech
at a military event drones dropped
explosives within striking distance of
the podium any time drones are used for
an attack what appears to have been an
assassination attempt
it's gravely concerning Wow he took us
to the command center
they watch for drones approaching the
border what you're seeing here is
primarily the Tucson area but he says
what concerns him the most is a
weaponized drone threatening the
Superbowl or even a White House where a
harmless drone landed in 2015
right now no law-enforcement
organization in the US can legally jam
or shoot down drones you want to take
control of these things and bring them
down if you have to or surveil them I
think we want the opportunity to have
all tools in the toolbox for our law
enforcement officers to identify good
from bad is a key component DHS wants
Congress to give it the power to
redirect disable disrupt control of
seized or confiscate without prior
consent a drone that poses a threat a
Senate committee approved legislation
over the summer but the bill is now
stalled with civil liberties
organizations saying that there is too
much room for error it's a problem
because it means that DHS can shoot a
drone out of the air or seize it and
they can do so without ever having a
judge look at their actions and
determine if they were right WOWY says
action is needed now this threat is upon
us today I wake up in the morning and
night just hoping we don't have an
attack Border Patrol's Rodolfo Karras
says drones they've seen along the
border are already capable of carrying
weapons there are drones now that have
the ability is to carry up to 300 pounds
if not more of a payload so that is a
significant risk for law enforcement
officers and agents in this country but
today
federal agents can only track a drone
and try to catch it when it lands after
that there is little Laos that they can
legally do Secret Service officials
would not get into what they would do if
a potentially threatening drone
approached the White House what US
officials will tell you privately is
that they have the capability to jam a
drone or take it down altogether they
will also tell you that the technology
with drones is evolving rapidly but the
laws are not Jeff buguese CBS News
Tucson Arizona drones are used for so
many good things beautiful pictures
protection but there's also another
scary side to that for you got to be
aware
you know it's been a big deal over in
Afghanistan and Iran to with it's very
dangerous what to do there